juste une question parce qu'on a perdu
gaspard ulliel il ya quelques semaines
maintenant parce qu'il y avait aussi
deux yves saint laurent au cinéma vous
aviez échanger sur vos prestations
respectives vous aviez vu son yves saint
laurent à lui et comment voulez vous
trouver bien sûr j'ai vu j'ai vu son
livre saint laurent à lui on échange et
pendant nos tournage ce qui était
étrange puisque moi quand je finissais
le mien il débuté le sien
il y avait des deux productions quand
même qu'ils se livraient une petite
guerre de cinéma ça vachement boosté par
des médias qui avait vachement envie
d'opposer les projets pour simplifier la
situation est pour bat pour vendre on
sait bien que le clash c'est plus
vendeur que la nuance on va dire
et gaspard au milieu de ça a toujours
été
vraiment d'une élégance et d'une
bienveillance d'une gentillesse total et
et puis c c'était quelqu'un avec un très
grand coeur et
ça me fait vraiment bizarre de parler
lui au passé c'est
ouais c'est à ce moment là on échange et
un peu alors on faisait tous les deux de
la moto on est devenu papa au même
moment quasiment
donc
donc on a échangé quelques fois sur ces
choses là maintenant ce n'était pas
quelqu'un ce n'était pas un ami proche
mais mais mais ça la manière dont
essayez toujours comporté avec moi alors
que tous nous pousser à sans doute se
méfier l'un de l'autre
j'ai toujours trouvé ça très classe mois
de sa part
pierre niney je vous invite du côté de
la bibliothèque on va rire aussi parce
qu'il ya pas mal de choses qui vont
j'espère